these buses are seen taking 18 nuns from
the order founded by mother teresa of
calcutta to nicaragua's southern border
to be expelled
the nuns had been working with the poor
and with children with learning
disabilities until the legislature
controlled by president daniel ortega's
sandinista party stripped them of their
legal status last week
they're the latest casualty of ortega's
unrelenting offensive against hundreds
of ngos and the catholic church whom he
calls coumongers and devils in robes
[Music]
the stunned nuns were received in
neighboring costa rica where a mass was
held to show them support
when you love god he's always present in
transformations
but when your values run counter to his
values there'll be of course persecution
the bishop was alluding to daniel
ortega's campaign against the catholic
church which includes the expulsion of
the vatican ambassador and the
imprisonment of a nicaraguan priest
the nuns thanked costa rica for its
hospitality but said they didn't want to
stay
we feel deep pain for being expelled
from nicaragua we want to return to what
we left behind people in need and three
communities where we worked
ironically they were expelled by the
same president who in the 1980s embraced
mother teresa and promised that her
order would always be welcome in
nicaragua
now with the nuns gone ortega awaits the
impending arrival of 230 russian troops
planes and ships for quote purposes of
training and law enforcement
ortega is a staunch ally of vladimir
putin which in the current global
context raises red flags in the region
the agreement puts ports airports and
military installations at the disposal
of the russians it's not the 180 or so
soldiers that matter it's the 50 72 eu
russian tanks bought in 2016 which
breaks the reasonable balance of power
in central america
nicaragua is also reportedly planning to
replace its cold war era katushka rocket
launchers and fighter planes with new
russian models
russian state media commented that it
was time that russian weapons got closer
to american cities
as for the nuns it's unlikely that their
prayers to return to nicaragua will be
answered soon
lucia newman al jazeera